[Music]
every industry is looking for smart
solutions to real-world problems using
data science which is why Udacity
collaborated with top companies to
create the data scientist nano degree
program data science is hugely important
to IBM these are the skills that we need
now to me the most exciting
collaboration is between people who have
deep experience and deep intuition about
an industry and then being able to
enrich that intuition with data I think
that is really where you hit the sweet
spot for the best kind of business
decision-making the biggest thing that
I'm trying to achieve every day is to
make sure that the technologies we use
in data science are available to
everybody in this program you'll build a
portfolio of projects focused on real
challenges crafted with industry input
I'm really excited that the project that
you density and then figure-eight are
doing together is focused on disaster
response and that's going to help us
have a positive impact in the world as
we respond to future disasters this
portfolio can get you connected to
valuable new job opportunities it is a
wonderful opportunity because of people
that are you know just enjoy learning
want to sort of level up and then also
have an impact well what I think that
the most important skill in a data
scientist is curiosity and the ability
to go and find your own answers when
they're not immediately evident and I
think that people who come in with a
Udacity training are already really
demonstrating that because you're
unafraid to go and teach yourself
something new take the leap forward with
Udacity in collaboration with industry
leaders and take a career to the next
level there's no better time than now
you